es una tradición Desde 1948 cuando la
asamblea general de Naciones Unidas
adoptó la declaración universal de
Derechos Humanos en el año de la
invasión rusa Ucrania el debate sobre el
respeto a los Derechos Humanos está
presente y han racchinski presidente le
International Memorial que es una de las
organizaciones que ganó el premio Nobel
de paz 2022 criticó la vulneración de
los Derechos civiles en Rusia
llevamos muchos años diciendo que un
país que viola los derechos humanos de
sus propios ciudadanos se vuelve
peligroso para el mundo exterior lo
venimos diciendo desde la Primera Guerra
de chechenia Y lamentablemente nadie
escuchó
más de 1.300 personas han sido detenidas
en Rusia por manifestarse en contra de
la guerra pero las organizaciones de
Derechos Humanos también apuntan a otros
países los iraníes llevan protestando
tres meses desde la muerte de la joven
kurda maxamini bajo custodia de la
policía de la moral el consejo de
seguridad e Irán reconoce la muerte de
más de 200 manifestantes pero la ong
Irán human Calcula más de 400 el 8 de
diciembre por primera vez las
autoridades ejecutaron públicamente a un
joven relacionado con las recientes
protestas a 7.000 kilómetros de Irán en
Filipinas manifestantes marcharon contra
el gobierno de ferdinan Marcos Junior al
que acusan de ejecuciones
extrajudiciales la ONU denuncia que en
lo corrido del año 250 personas han
muerto en medio de redadas policiales
contra el narcotráfico y las
investigaciones judiciales no avanzan se
han archivado siete procesos que
implicaban a 25 funcionarios
gubernamentales en las ejecuciones